on this tuesday night access denied
the taliban blocks afghans from going to
the kabul airport as video emerges of
afghans outside the airport pleading
with canadian soldiers
we have visas
nobody is talking about could canada
stay beyond the august 31st deadline the
pressure on president biden plus did the
head of the cia meet the taliban leader
political popularity grading the liberal
strategy to try to win a majority
return of the masks the province is
mandating people to cover up again as
covet cases climb
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
after days of chaos at kabul airport
another sign not all afghans desperate
to flee the taliban will make it out the
taliban now says it will still allow
foreigners to leave but will no longer
allow afghans to go to the airport
thousands of vulnerable people including
those who risk their lives working for
the canadian military may be left behind
and the august 31st deadline is looming
good evening and thanks for joining us
president joe biden said today he
intends to stick to that deadline
evacuation flights are more rapid now
the u.s and its allies have airlifted
out more than 21 000 people in the last
24 hours the canadian government says
more than two thousand people have been
brought to canada in recent weeks and
tonight the government released this
photo showing what it says is another
500 people who left kabul yesterday it's
not clear how many on board this flight
are canadians and how many are afghan
citizens
and this video was taken outside kabul
airport obtained by global news it's the
first images of canadian special forces
on the ground operating in the crowds of
afghans hoping to board flights some of
the afghans worked as interpreters and
say they have visas and papers but are
being ignored by the canadian soldiers
we are telling them here here's our
visas
we have documents
we have visas nobodies
nobody is talking to us
prime minister justin trudeau was
pressed today about making good on his
promise to bring more than 20 thousand
afghans to canada he said canada may
stay in kabul pass the august 31st
deadline if possible to keep evacuations
going
i emphasize that canada is ready to stay
beyond the 31st deadline if it's at all
possible because we want to save as many
people as possible and canadians
are ready to work to try and do that
the prime minister joined western
leaders in a g7 emergency meeting about
afghanistan today all of them grappling
with the urgency of the evacuation and
what happens next under taliban rule
redmond shannon has our top story
tonight
lives squeezed into a wheelbarrow with a
deadline fast approaching throngs of
people remain outside kabul airport
despite the urgent evacuation efforts of
the past week
canada picked up 500 people monday more
than 70 000 people have been flown out
so far the vast majority by the us
countries like the uk france and germany
say there is not enough time left to fly
out everyone they want by the august
31st deadline
british prime minister boris johnson
convened a g7 leaders meeting tuesday
with the goal of convincing u.s
president joe biden to push back the
deadline johnson failed biden not
bending for now so johnson is urging the
taliban to allow an extension for other
nations and to respect human rights amid
reports of violations they include among
others
summary executions of civilians and all
the combat members of the afghan
national security forces restrictions on
the right of women afghanistan can't
lurch back into becoming a breeding
ground of terror afghanistan i can't
become a narco state
girls have got to be educated up to the
age of 18. offering the carrot of
economic engagement in the future
because the g7
has very considerable leverage uh
economic diplomatic and uh and political
uh no no but the other one earlier a
taliban spokesperson repeated the
group's demand that the august 31st
deadline be met now blocking afghan
nationals from going to the airport
the taliban made a similar demand two
weeks before the previous deadline
earlier this year but crucially that was
before taliban forces took control of
kabul there may be a split within the g7
over the departure deadline but in a
joint statement the group said the
taliban will be held accountable for its
actions however with china russia and
other regional powers also potentially
looking to get involved in afghanistan's
future that economic leverage of the g7
may not be as strong as prime minister
johnson would hope redmond shannon
global news london
many canadians are working to help get
afghans who worked with our soldiers as
interpreters and guides out of the
country staying behind almost certainly
condemns them to death at the hands of
the taliban some have made it out but as
mike armstrong reports others are still
pleading for help from canadian soldiers
who are now outside kabul's airport
these are the only images we've seen of
canadian troops on the ground in
afghanistan it was shared with global
news by a veterans group working to get
afghan interpreters out of the country
and was according to that group shot by
an afghan interpreter
here are canadians forces over there
we came here since
6 a.m morning we are waiting here
no canadian forces is hearing our vice
this is a rush
against time retired general david
frazier is part of the veterans group he
says they've been able to get visas for
about 15 percent of the families they're
trying to help that leaves 85 percent
still stuck so far how many have gotten
out
only 3 percent it's gotten better but
it's not good enough
we've still got people on the ground
that need to get out
global news spoke to one of those former
interpreters we're protecting his
identity he says he has visas to go to
canada for himself and his wife but not
for his children
they have six
i can't live without the children
and where should i leave them
i mean there's no place there's no one
right here in afghanistan
the interpreter says he's been to the
airport twice with his family and both
times hasn't seen canadian soldiers or
officials he can't keep going back
because it's too dangerous they have to
go through taliban checkpoints
they were hitting the people they were
clearing the the documents and i
couldn't able to show them any
these kind of documents like like i
worked with the canadians
now reaching the airport is becoming
harder and harder the taliban has
promised safe passage to people trying
to leave by plane but there are more and
more reports of beatings at checkpoints
and people being turned around
mike armstrong global news
without american support the evacuation
mission would collapse and u.s president
joe biden is still sticking to the
august 31st deadline a deadline his
administration negotiated with the
taliban biden is projecting calm when
the world can see the chaotic desperate
scenes at the airport our washington
bureau chief jackson proskow is with me
jackson the biden administration has
been negotiating with the taliban for a
long time now and now the head of the
cia has gone to kabul that's right donna
you know this curious development
actually unfolded yesterday a secret
meeting in kabul between the cia
director and the de facto leader of the
taliban it's the highest level meeting
involving the u.s and the taliban since
the militant group seized control of
afghanistan u.s officials are framing
these talks as being operational and
tactical centered around the continued
efforts to evacuate u.s citizens and
allied afghans the cia director though
is an interesting choice as chief
negotiator here given the long and
complex history between the cia and
taliban and given that the taliban
leader was actually captured and
imprisoned as a result of a cia
operation years ago but the white house
insists they need the cooperation of the
militant group to finish the airlift by
august 31st and they admit they are
making contingency plans just in case
they can't meet that deadline the
taliban have been taking steps to work
with us so we can get our people out
but it's a tenuous situation
we're already had some gun fighting
break out
we run a serious risk of it breaking
down as time goes on
jackson this is the biggest foreign
policy challenge of biden's presidency
he promised an orderly withdrawal it's
been anything but so how much is this
affecting biden's image and reputation
well for the first time in his uh young
presidency he's actually under water in
his approval ratings just 41 percent
approve of the job he's doing as
president 55 now disapprove and it
really is his handling of the
afghanistan situation that's dragging
him down here just 26 percent of
americans say they approve of the job
he's doing handling that file even
though a majority of americans in
principle support the idea of
withdrawing u.s forces from afghanistan
we should point out that to date 77 000
people have been airlifted out of that
country and tonight u.s troops are
slowly starting their drawdown in
anticipation of leaving ahead of that
looming deadline
okay jackson prosco in washington thanks
now to the federal election here in
canada we are into week two of the
campaign and though the first week is
usually long forgotten by voting day it
is worth taking stock of where things
stand which leader has momentum right
now and what issues have thrown
campaigns off topic mercedes stevenson
is in hamilton ontario traveling with
the liberal campaign
donna for the liberals things have not
been going according to plan in the
early days of the campaign the
deteriorating situation in afghanistan
has followed the liberal leader from
coast to coast and here today in
hamilton he was asked whether he can
balance his attention on a foreign
policy crisis as well as a political
campaign where winning is all or nothing
canadians across the country
are thinking about yes afghanistan but
they're also thinking about how they're
going to get through this pandemic how
their kids are going to get back to
school
when they're not vaccinated and stay
safe afghanistan isn't the only timing
issue for the liberal leader the optics
of calling an election in the middle of
a fourth wave of covet 19 have continued
to follow him and while the liberals
want to frame this as an election about
big ideas so far the party has been
short on them and the liberal leader has
not committed to releasing the party's
platform before the debate and the sunny
ways of years past has this time been
punctuated with edited videos of his
main rival wedge issues like mandatory
vaccines and even attacks on provincial
political rivals including a threat to
claw back health care dollars from
saskatchewan over private mri clinics so
far the strategy isn't playing well the
liberals have squandered the five-point
lead they held over the conservatives
heading into the election a new poll
from ipso suggests the conservatives and
liberals are now statistically tied the
pool also found justin trudeau's
popularity is down with his approval
rating dipping below 50 percent for the
first time during the covet 19 pandemic
ipsos found 33 percent of voters would
support the liberals if the election
were held tomorrow that's down three
points from last week while the
conservatives went up a point to 32
percent of the vote discussions in
political circles have shifted from a
majority to the possibility of another
minority and while there are just a few
weeks left in the campaign and justin
trudeau has shown himself to be a strong
campaigner and anything could change he
may need more than his record and his
current promises to win over voters
donna mercedes thanks the conservative
leader erin o'toole is promising to
protect employee pension plans to ensure
the money deducted from paychecks will
be there when people retire if elected
he says his party will change the law to
prevent what he calls corporate elites
from giving themselves perks when their
companies are in financial trouble and
workers pensions are at risk
we will prevent executives from paying
themselves large bonuses while managing
a company going through restructuring if
the pension isn't properly funded
and today the ndp focused on long-term
care we'll have more on its plan to end
for-profit care homes a little bit later
first to the pandemic the manitoba
government says all front-line
provincial employees who work with
vulnerable people are required to be
fully vaccinated by october 31st or
undergo regular testing that includes
health care providers and teachers
premier brian pallister says the public
health orders will help protect children
who cannot be vaccinated avoid another
lockdown and stave off a dangerous
fourth wave in manitoba he is also
bringing back the provincial mask
mandate for all indoor public spaces
bc is as well that province's top doctor
says starting tomorrow masks will be
required for people 12 and older in
places like grocery stores malls
restaurants and public transit dr bonnie
henry says bc's case count has been
creeping up the province also revealed
its back-to-school plan students will
return to full-time in-person learning
sports music and other extracurricular
activities there will be no cohorts
masks will still be required for
students in grades four to twelve they
will also be mandatory for kindergarten
to grade 12 staff and visitors to
schools
the most important thing we can do to
protect children who are not yet
eligible for vaccines and we do hope
there will be vaccines particularly for
the the six to twelve year age group by
sometime this fall
but the most important thing we can do
to protect them is to make sure that the
adults around them are immunized
there's still no requirement for
teachers in bc to be vaccinated but
vaccination will be required in many
places on post-secondary campuses
including gyms restaurants and sporting
events and those living in on-campus
housing will also require proof of
vaccination
in quebec the new school year begins
this week for some students and today
that province announced those in grade
one and older will have to wear masks
inside the classroom in nine regions of
the province including montreal students
in the other regions will be required to
wear masks in school common areas and on
buses the government says it's to help
avoid closures and online learning
because of the surge of the delta
variant with cases rising quebec is
pushing ahead with its vaccine passport
system it comes into effect september
1st proof of vaccination will be
required for people age 13 and older to
access non-essential services like
restaurants movie theaters and gyms it
will not be needed for retail stores two
mobiles app will be available for
download on ap on apple from eight
morning tomorrow and soon on google i
think it's a matter of a day or two
maximum quebec was the first province to
announce the vaccine passport as a way
to prevent lockdowns as cases surge and
one more pandemic note the northwest
territories has confirmed its first
death related to covet 19. the chief
public health officer there says a
resident died late last night the
territory is experiencing its worst
outbreak since the pandemic began there
are now 219 active cases
a pitch to fix canada's long-term care
homes coming up the ndp's proposal to
protect the most vulnerable
[Music]
ndp leader jug meat singh used a
campaign stop at a long-term care
facility in ontario to make the case for
an end to profit-making long-term care
homes more than fourteen thousand
residents in care homes died in the
first and second waves of the pandemic
and all the major parties have
substantial policy proposals to better
protect those living in long-term care
our chief political correspondent david
aiken takes a closer look
the pandemic data has been crystal clear
the vast majority of coven 19 deaths in
canada were in long-term care homes and
those in long-term care homes operated
for profit were sick and died at a much
higher rate than those in non-profit
homes you know the research is quite
clear overwhelmingly not-for-profit has
provided a better quality of care than
for-profit homes that's why the ndp is
pushing a ban on the practice of running
long-term care homes for profit we've
said really clearly it is wrong that
for-profit exists in this system that
there is there should be no profit that
puts people
as a less priority than than profits and
money maureen mcdermott's 91 year old
mother died of covid in a for-profit
long-term care facility the stories are
horrendous
profits do not belong inside of
long-term care and in fact
profits kill
seniors
singh and mcdermott push for the ban
while standing outside of the corporate
headquarters of rivera that's a private
for-profit ltc operator controlled
coincidentally by the federal public
sector pension investment board a crown
corporation
out of all private for-profit long-term
care operators they actually have the
highest number of deaths in canada over
860 deaths across 56 facilities neither
the liberals nor the conservatives agree
with a ban on for-profit ltc facilities
but each party has made substantial
commitments on long-term care the
conservatives would set aside three
billion dollars for upgrades and repairs
to long-term care homes and have
promised to quote encourage non-profit
operators the liberals are promising to
spend nine billion dollars on long-term
care establish a minimum wage of 25
dollars an hour for personal support
workers and hire 50 000 more of them
and so for the first time in a federal
election taking care of people in
long-term care homes is a major campaign
issue and advocates are hoping that
after all this election talk there's
some action when the vote is done donna
well everybody hoping for that david
aiken in mississauga thanks
ahead record-breaking wildfires scorch
california
crews are racing to prevent an explosive
wildfire from getting any closer to
california's popular lake tahoe region
the calder fire is blazed through more
than 42 thousand hectares in just nine
days and incinerated at least 500 homes
and other structures wildfires in
california have now scorched more land
than at this point in last year's
record-setting fire season with climate
change making conditions hotter and
drier experts warn california may not
see any relief until december
new york state has a new governor
that's kathy hochol she was sworn in
during a private ceremony at the state
capitol the 62 year old democrat and
former congresswoman from buffalo says
she wants people to believe in their
government again she takes the reins
after andrew cuomo resigned rather than
face a likely impeachment an independent
investigation led by the state's
attorney general found there was
credible evidence cuomo sexually
harassed at least 11 women
and that is global national for this
tuesday i'm donna friesen we leave you
tonight with team canada marching on the
world stage at the opening ceremony of
the tokyo paralympics the flag bearer
for canada was priscilla gagne she's a
metal contender in judo 128 canadian
athletes are competing good luck to all
of them
thanks for watching
take care of yourselves bye-bye
[Music]
you